what's going on everybody welcome to
another pandas tutorial video in this
video we're gonna be talking about is
how we can modify various columns and
stuff like this within pandas so to
start we'll just take this code here all
the way down to print D F head we can
continue printing that ahead there just
for now and now I wanted to show you
guys some of the column operations that
we can do so first off if you wanted to
let's say only reference one specific
column in conjunction with the index you
could do something like this so for now
I'll just put a number you could just
rename what DF was so you're not storing
DF in the memory and then what we're
saying here is DF - so you're not
storing DF 2 in a memory but so we can
kind of go through this tutorial
linearly this is what we'll do so DF 2
is going to equal D F and just open okay
and so now we'll say print DF 2 dot and
the output we get is just date and open
okay so that's all we get when we do
something like that so we if we just
want to specify one column that's all we
do now the next thing is if you want to
specify multiple columns you would do
something like make some space DF 3
equals D F and then brackets and then
we're gonna make a list so brackets
within brackets and we're gonna say
let's say we want to have clothes and we
also want to have open okay so we can go
ahead and now do print you have three
dot head run that there we go
and we come down here and we have
clothes open day and all that so now we
have just referencing like those two
columns now this will work with as many
columns as you want you could make this
close open high and so on so now the
next thing that we want to do is
we could say for example let's say we
want to I guess put the next thing I'll
show you guys is we can delete columns
as well so right now DF 3 has these
right it's got it closed and open what
we could do is we could say del DF 3
oops not def del DF 3 and then close and
then we'll again print DF 3 head
save and run that and now we've actually
deleted that column so a couple of
things that we could do is one we could
just if we wanted to just delete one
column we could do that or you can just
redefine that same variable and dump
whatever you know was stored in there
before it just depends on what you're
looking for if you're just looking to
make like one change you might as well
just delete or something like that
so the next thing that we're gonna do is
we can also rename columns so I'm gonna
go ahead and get rid of this delete for
now and let's go ahead and rename
clothes so we could say something like
this DF 4 equals DF 3 and then in
brackets here we're gonna say we're
actually rather the F 4 equals let's say
the F 3 dot rename and we're gonna
rename columns equals and basically
where the column is equal to close we're
gonna say we want to rename that to all
caps close okay and then what we'll do
on outside of this bracket is we're
gonna say imp oops let's say in plate in
place equals true and that's it now
let's go ahead and create df4 dot save
and run it
three I guess it's not gonna let us do
what I wanted to do well instead then
what we can do is this it's odd that I
can't get away with this anyway so we'll
say DF three equal those that run it
again and this time we do get a warning
but it still comes through so it renames
closed with all caps closed and this
warning is something to do with like
chained right okay so anyway the that
could get problematic as you go on but
for our purposes of just renaming a
column that's how you how you're gonna
do it if somebody has a better way that
won't annoy setting with copy warning
let me know but there's nothing wrong
with doing it this way as far as I know
so now the next thing another thing I
could show you guys is so for example we
have let's go ahead and just print DF 3
so this will be kind of a longer version
here so this is DF 3 as you can see
we've got quite a few numbers - it goes
1300s and 1400s well let's say that we
only want to consider where the where
the value is higher than 1400 so we can
actually throw in conditionals here so
we could say something like this we
could say DF 4 equals DF 3 and then in
brackets here we're gonna say DF 3 and
we said close so we're gonna say we're
close is greater than 1400 so we're
basically throwing an if statement in
here
so what we're saying is DF 4 equals DF 3
where DF 3 s close is greater than 1400
and we can do this also with intz and
all that not in sorry strings and it's
obviously in floats whatever and you can
use greater than equal than and all that
stuff so or exactly equal to and so on
so now what we can do is we can say well
let's print DF 4 and now all we get
obviously we get this
massive list but all we get is so let's
see here oh these were opens okay so
that's why I was like no anyway close we
can see all of the closes here our
closes where they're above 1,400 okay so
anyway those are just some brief example
of all the things that we can do so we
can reference just a specific column we
could rename if we only wanted to
consider that column we can reference
multiple columns using the list we can
delete columns with del and we can also
select well we can change names and then
finally we can select using conditional
statements specific bits of data based
on that conditional statement that you
throw in there so those are just some
really really quick commands that we can
do there's still a whole lot of other
things that we can do with columns but
those are just some quick basics that
you are probably going to want to be
able to do so anyway that's gonna
conclude this tutorial video if you guys
have any questions or comments for free
leave those below as always thanks for
watching things for all the support
subscriptions and until next time